There are 206 bones in the human body, and
yes, it’s the same for men and women.
No, women don’t have fewer ribs than men,
and men don’t have one extra bone, if you
know what I mean.
You know what I mean.
But several mammals, including our close relatives
like chimpanzees, do have that extra bone,
so today let’s talk about why other animals
have penis bones while humans got the shaft.
It wasn’t always this way.
Researchers who traced its evolutionary timeline
found the penis bone, also known by its scientific
and less fun name the baculum, first evolved
around 145 million years ago after placental
and non-placental mammals split.
This means that way back, our ancestors had
a baculum, and on the way to being human they
lost it.
The researchers put that about 1.9 million
years ago.
Ironically, in the time of Homo erectus.
The reason why we lost our baculum may be
down to our mating strategy.
Baculum length in primates is closely correlated
with intromission time, which is how long
the penis is inside the vagina.
If a primate is going to spend a longer time
doing their monkey business, it helps to prop
up their banana.
What constitutes a long intromission?
According to the researchers, 3 minutes, and
humans don’t quite make the cut.
Our average time from penetration to ejaculation
is less than two minutes, so it looks like
we just don’t need the extra support.
There are primates like bonobos who copulate
for 15 seconds at a time, and yet they still
have a baculum.
This might be because they’re polygamous
primates, where many males mate with many
females, meaning competition is stiff so they
have to be too.
In other polygamous species, having a bone
in their boner will help keep them copulating
longer, so other males don’t get a chance
with their lady.
They are, quite literally, cock blocking.
By comparison humans face less competition
for mates because of our monogamous mating
strategy.
And that along with short intromission times
may be why our baculum was lost to history.
You may think we got stiffed, but I have some
news that’ll pick you up.
Penis bones come in all shapes and sizes,
and while some of them are impressive and
slightly terrifying, like the 2 foot baculum
of the walrus, plenty of them aren’t.
Chimps, for example, have a baculum about
the size of your fingernail.
In fact even without the extra skeletal bone,
humans still have the biggest penises of the
great apes.
So, you know what, I don’t miss it.
Great news!
Amazingly nobody owns the domain name walrusbaculum.com.
You can register it or any other great domain
name before someone else does, and you can
do it with Domain dot com.
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and have all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
For more on that crazy walrus baculum watch
Carin talk about it on Wild Sex, here.
Make sure you subscribe for more videos and
remember…
Gorillas, with all their chest-thumping, only
have a 2.5 inch penis.
Showing yet again, that we are all compensating
for something.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.